it's not a really funny film about
sibling Roger later and I danced on
finishing it I knew he had a couple
other projects come on your own the
meantime yes um but so many people have
great ideas and they never implement
them um so once you decide on a movie
there was a huge commitment how long do
you spend the two of you kicking around
an idea before you actually manifest it
well we definitely it's a good question
we do spend a ton of time I mean most of
our energy goes into constantly talking
about an idea and making sure that it
has the weight and they have to to to
carry us for two years and because we're
very picky people and you know we we get
fussy really easily so we have to
totally be in love with it know that it
has the depth and the breadth to explore
for that long go to right um so many
people in LA wanna be where you are and
right in these chairs yeah probably
right in these chairs right in front of
him yeah but but in terms you know naam
ke yeah you know where you are success
wise as many people don't realize the
hustle that it takes we know we've
talked to you before that sometimes you
don't get vacations and you're working I
mean mark you're constantly busy so how
are you handling NV it's a very very
sort of bits that elephant in the room
that people don't want to talk about in
this industry it's very very true how do
you handle that graciously or maybe not
so gracious you know I mean it's
interesting i think that on paper our
careers look really really great and
they would be appetizing to to a lot of
people you know but i think that also
once people start to get close to us and
realize you know how hard we work and
how grueling it is and how even though
it looks like we're having a blast all
day on set improvising it's really hard
work and kind of stressful to you know I
think the end becomes way down at that
point and they realize it's as hard as
any other job you know but you know when
you live in Los Angeles is a town full
of filmmakers and actors and and there
are definitely moments you know where
you where you run into people who
are less successful than you and you can
feel that you know and and I mean I
guess you know the only thing I can say
is that we're still envious of tons of
filmmakers too and we're doing it to
other people as well and I think I guess
every profession has it to a certain
degree it's like a karmic wheel yes
exactly everybody wants what they don't
have very true yeah anything yeah yeah
totally agree with Marc about that and I
would just say that we are constantly
obsessed in challenging ourselves to
make better things and to make different
things and to just explore different
issues and you know where we're doing
this because we love it and because we
you know kind of are obsessed by it so
we actually don't really even pause very
much or enough to to really consider
those elements that much like Mark said
you do feel it and it will occur to you
every once in a while but we constantly
feel like we're climbing a mountain and
that we are underdogs trying to you know
trying to do something new and trying to
do something different we feel like
making a really good film is an almost
impossible task no matter who you are I
mean you know we saw an interview with
Francis Ford Coppola who in the 80s said
that his goal currently was to make an
original piece of art which he felt he
hadn't done in 10 years and that Nick
just just knocked us over and made us
realize that it's always a struggle to
make a unique special piece of art I
mean we worked with Susan Sarandon
recently on jeff who lives at home and
she showed up on set and was nervous as
hell and was you know taking chances and
falling on her face and it was just it
is revitalizing and invigorating and
scary as hell too because you realize
that like nobody's nobody's got it
locked up you know everyone is
constantly trying to to to make
something original to mine the depths of
their own being and
you know that quest for me and mark is
never ending so I don't know it's we
ought we always feel like we're doing it
for the first time
you